boy are we busy bees these days and i
appreciate the time uh i'm assuming
we have set the over under chris what's
the overrun a number of times we hear
his phone buzzing during the
conversation at three i'm going to say
yeah and a half is great
so uh what was the decision making by
the chiefs today
the you know the obviously we're outside
the building and we saw the super bowl
we saw mahomes is still running for his
life
because those two tackles weren't there
and now the two tackles won't be there
what what what's going on here with that
decision yeah so
this is one where you know obviously it
happens this morning
and i think you know one i think
mitchell schwartz we knew was coming
he's got some decisions to make about
what he wants to do
when he gets healthy so i think you know
play or not i think that was
you know probably not a surprise um
the fisher one you know was a surprise
and then you sort of think about it then
it really should be obvious because
you know obviously patrick mahomes is
running for his life in the super bowl
that's why these moves were made because
eric fisher
has a torn achilles and it is a cold
world
but he's not going to be healthy until
september or
maybe even october they have to get
better at tackle so if you got mitchell
schwartz who just had surgery
eric fisher's who's you know early on in
his rehab
that means they need two tackles to
start the season that means they need
money to have two tackles to start the
season and that's why
this happened so that's you know it was
i mean i knew about mitchell schwartz i
did not know about eric fisher but then
thinking about it this morning just like
to enter my world a little bit
i was frustrated because you know
he posted on instagram and i'm like ah
should have known that was coming it
makes sense
so uh what does this mean uh ian
about what to expect because we've never
seen
there's been a ton of firsts man i mean
from a 43 year old
winning a super bowl right to you doing
an interview while
uh microwaving something to um
okay to to somebody like wentz
uh underperforming after signing a
monster nine figure deal and then the
guy was taken in front of him
also traded away i mean it's just
there just seems to be different ways of
of of looking at the
the unparalleled uh present
and now the cap is down like i i i don't
think
you know knock on wood will ever see
that again what are we expecting here
oh over the next 90 hours ian
what are you expecting it's not not a
lot of good things honestly
uh more of what we've got and you know
it's weird because this year's been
weird for so many reasons we've had
you know the deshaun watson situation
which i think probably has escalated to
a point where most of us did not see it
going
you have the russell wilson situation
like i remember when we were talking on
game day morning during the super bowl
and teams were calling about russell and
i was like
oh well this would be interesting to see
if you know this becomes and then it all
went crazy and now we're here
um i think the next week or so is going
to be
more like almost like the opposite
because you're what you're going to see
is a lot of guys caught a lot of big
names cut that we're used to seeing on
the field
and then they'll have the decision
should i accept this lower salary
or should i
you know just wait and so that's why
like it's going to be a weird free
agency i mean there'll be big deals of
the excitement
but then you're also going to see some
veterans who we know who are pro bowlers
who are recognizable names
going i'm not getting what i want i'm
just gonna sit here
um and it it might be a slower free
agency than we've seen before
well yeah the slower free agency meaning
that uh offers that normally would go
out
are are held back because you know
a lower or low ball however you want to
view it offer is on the table so
give me the blockbuster ones that you
think are definitely going to get done
is juju smith schuster one of them
kenny galladay one of them who do you
defensive players one of them i'm really
curious about
i mean gallaudet is really interesting
obviously he's incredibly talented
you know everybody knows that didn't
play much last year
and then you know i think he's going to
have a good market but his own team
didn't franchise them
that is at least something that teams
are going to look into because they have
the space they could have done it
so why is it just fresh start new coach
is you know do you want to pay a lot for
a receiver
when you have jared i don't know um but
it's definitely something teams are
going to look into juju's another one
big name flashy has played great
has been up and down kind of recently
like i wouldn't be surprised if juju
takes a really really strong
one-year deal and goes you know what
lowered cap
like i'd rather take a one-year bet of
myself and go kill it the following year
like that actually makes sense to me so
um you know i think we'll see some
you know shaq bear will probably get a
huge deal he might
he might be the winner of all this he
might get the biggest deal okay some
offensive lineman like joe tooney is
going to do great trent williams is
going to make a ton like
those more of the guys we're talking
instead of like some of the skill
position guys like you know aaron jones
or some of the receivers
okay so let's put a pin in and and one
of the names you just mentioned
and aaron jones um because i'm i'm
intrigued by him
um certainly since somebody like travis
atiena uh
reportedly ran a 4-4 flat unofficials
i'm seeing from our
colleagues at the nfl network uh
assignment desk and
information desk um so
what about shaq barrett let's get into
the bucks because jason light's got a
ton
of free agents and they they franchise
godwin they get levante david
to a two-year barrett is barrack gonna
hit it
with and stay with the bucks or somebody
else
what do you got for me there i think
everybody hopes it's with the bucks i
mean other teams don't they'd like to
sign them but
everyone involved hopes it's with the
bucks and you know
he is a he's a great player he has found
himself with tampa bay
so like you know he's going to make a
lot of money anyway
and the bucks have some gymnastics to do
to try to make it happen
but why would he want to leave right
like if i was
if i was a pass rusher and todd bowles
defense one i'd be a lot taller but two
like i would never want to leave
you know like he gets the most out of
guys and he helps them be really
productive
so i i to me i would be surprised if
shaq barrett ended up leaving the box
that would be
that would be a pretty surprising free
agent development i would say
and the maneuvering that you're saying
that the the bucks need to do to i guess
move things around shift things around
does that involve tom brady getting
extended
what do you got for me on that yeah i
think yeah i think that's something
that's been in the works the last couple
days you know it probably ends up as a
one-year extension
trade cap space a little more guarantee
um give them some room this year and
like
you know i think anybody who watched
brady sees a player who
does not somehow appear to be on the
downside
um so he's sticking around at least
definitely next year which i think
obviously he is
and maybe the year after which seems
probably the case too
then locking him in for another year and
giving yourself
cap room makes a lot of sense and then
uh
do you take that money and give it to
godwin or cause
uh both jason light when he was on this
show and bruce arians
said uh that they they feel that they
can keep everybody
that they need to keep who's on the list
of the need to keep do you think
uh from the 20 somewhat unrestricted
gronk is one of them huh
yeah i think i mean he i know he's
coming back they would like him back
um you know i i will see what the actual
salary ends up being i don't think he's
going to come back for like a dollar
um but you know i mean she's willing to
take a pay cut from last year like i
found that hard to believe so we'll see
what the actual number is
you know and then and then you have
antonio brown um who
wants to be back with the bucks they
want him back brady wants him back
what's that number going to be you know
it's net is you know as
as we've learned we've talked about it's
never going to be as high as you think
especially in this ridiculous year
so what does he end up being willing to
accept to play with tom brady again
like i think that's i think that's a
legitimate question
um and his market's gonna be fascinating
too ian rappaport here
on the rich eisen show i i fear asking
these
this question because it could be dated
literally five minutes after it's out of
my mouth
but here we are the thursday before the
new league year begins and drew brees
has
not announced his retirement yet as a
matter of fact greg olsen
greg olsen has has beaten him to the
announcement of a retirement that we've
all expected
uh i believe that's going down as you
and i are talking
what is going on there and how does it
affect
what is going on in new orleans with all
of the cap
uh casualties for that team that had
super bowl aspirations and still does
obviously what do you got for me it does
not affect new orleans cap wise because
once i mean we've known he's retiring
we've said it a million times
but it was definitely clinched when he
redid his contract i think it was during
super bowl week actually
um and basically took the minimum salary
this year and then
when he retires the salaries at the end
will go away and anybody so like
he did what he needed to do salary wise
to help the team operating free agency
so like
we know he's retiring he knows he's
retiring he hasn't announced it would be
hilarious is it for him to announce it
like
wednesday at 11 a.m or something when
like we're all planning to talk about
free agency and now drew brees announces
his retirement you have all networks on
like 100 of the time we're talking about
drew brees like that would be kind of
funny
actually that may happen um but it
doesn't matter because they are moving
on at quarterback and he's moving on it
just hasn't
he hasn't made it announcement official
yet they're moving on to who
you know it feels like jameis winston to
me i would be surprised if there's
anyone else you know
it's just it's it's a situation where
his market is better
i think he's got the best market in new
orleans i think they make the most sense
for him
he makes the most sense for them they
haven't settled on a number yet but like
that's where it feels like it's going
and where does the quarterback come out
i'd be surprised if it's not jamming
okay so where does a quarterback
carousel feel as if it
is where where it is going with alex
smith
and ryan fitzpatrick right and
uh also the the bears needing uh
somebody and the sam darnold could be
that somebody for someone what is going
on with jimmy g
i mean there are so many questions about
it
uh we're i i just kind of will throw it
out there and say where do you see
the quarterback carousel going and let's
start with
the watson and wilson scenarios is there
any shots let's run through it okay go
for it let's start with them
all right watson no timeline
if anything happens at all which i'm not
convinced it will
it's not gonna be anytime soon maybe by
the draft but honestly maybe not even
then
russell wilson i know this team's
interested the bears haven't mentioned
they are definitely interested um i
haven't gotten the sense on any momentum
toward a trade
and the biggest question for seattle
would be like if you're gonna tread
russell wilson
okay fine you're gonna get a lot for him
who's your quarterback and
i don't have an answer to that question
which is obviously a significant problem
um i don't get the sense jimmy g is
going anywhere
you know if the niners could upgrade
would they trade him
you know probably they probably would i
just don't know who would be an upgrade
so i think they
i think he sticks there darnold probably
gets
traded if he gets traded i don't know
for sure i don't know for sure he's
getting traded but
it's going to be more toward the middle
of april or maybe even draft week if it
happens
um just because that by then the jets
will have settled on who they would take
at number two
um you have you know marcus mariota
who you know probably ends up getting
released i think teams are waiting for
him to get released
and then he'll factor into this you
mentioned alex smith
um he's got a lot of interest um as a
really good backup slash mentor as he
should
you know the bears make a lot of sense
to me because of matt nagy
uh the jaguars make a lot of sense i
think both
both of those teams are interested
no i'm trying to get over i'm trying to
just pick and choose what
my follow-up is let's let's pull on alex
smith i mean
so his choice will be uh starting for
the bears if the bears finally
whittle down their options to him or
he's the mr chips for for trevor
lawrence
uh for his old college coach because and
ryan fitzpatrick you know would want to
you know he could sit there ryan
fitzpatrick could just go on any team he
knows he'll be the starter eventually i
mean that's just the way it always goes
him going to the patriots would be
perfect one i mean
he's he played well last year he would
complete that it would completely
it would it it would complete the uh
superfecta
right wouldn't it circle of life the afc
super factory he'd hit all four yes that
happens
yeah and that's i mean to me like i
don't need a reason to see ryan
fitzpatrick with the patriots because i
think it'll be great
but that's a good enough reason if i
needed one
what is new england's option what what
would they do
where where do you think they're going
ian that's a fascinating thing we're
going somewhere
um you know draft was dr draft would be
obviously a big thing for them
could definitely draft a quarterback um
you know
hard for me to imagine cam goes back
there unless they have no other option
um you know if marcus mariota is free
i think they'd have some interest um
i don't think tim donald's getting
traded there although that would be kind
of funny that would never happen
um i mean literally something very warm
would have to freeze over
so thick and so deep that not even the
fortress of solitude would match it in
terms of the thickness of the ice
to be very honest with you yeah i mean
it would just yeah but what makes you
feel bad
what makes you think jimmy g's not going
anywhere because obviously that would be
uh one would think an option to have him
pick pictures would make a lot of sense
i just it's the same thing as the
seahawks like the 49ers obviously last
year they were bad but
they seem like a team that's ready to
compete who is going to be their
quarterback that's the main problem with
all this stuff
is so much of this quarterback talk is
out in the open now which is great
because it gives us something to talk
about
right and also it's fun but the answer
is still like
who is their quarterback that is better
than they previously had and i
cannot find an answer to that question
all right so let me bounce my crazy uh
fantasy football
uh uh possibility off of the the real
football world that you're so
attuned to um watson and tua switched
spots
the jets trade darnold to the niners um
who wind up sending jimmy g
to the patriots what do you think and
they and they choose zach wilson second
overall
what do you think of that that all
happens and much of that happens draft
week
with the darnold uh to the niners
and the niners jimmy g the patriots
uh happens the second night of the draft
after they choose zack wilson the night
before
sort of similar to josh rosen yeah it's
sort of similar or or
and or three this year that they can
exact later on on friday night and won
the following year
something like that what do you think
about that i think they should i think
they should do it all
um also my head would explode sitting
there on the set or my right perch on
draft night but i would
probably go into shock it's not crazy is
it is it crazy
is that nutty yeah yeah all of it's
crazy absolutely um
but i think it'd be fun and you know if
i would say this if the salary cap was
not a thing
and the texans were a little more open
to dealing to sean watson that which and
if they like tua
which i do not know if they do or not
but
i i don't know i don't know um that
could all be great
i just seemed a little slightly
far-fetched for our universe but good
thought okay thank you ian before i let
you go your two cents on the dac signing
what do you think about that one uh one
of the best contracts i've seen
negotiated
uh by a player and agent in a very long
time
and for the cowboys like i loved what
jerry said
i mean now he's always crazy but
everything of value he's had he's always
over paid for i thought that was perfect
yes he overpaid for dac yes they could
have gotten cheaper if they've done them
two years ago
the reality is the cowboys end up with a
franchise quarterback that's better than
most of the other
teams that have quarterbacks and they
paid a lot for him
but that's okay because he is very good
and he's everything you'd want to be
as the face of your franchise so i'm sad
i'm not going to talk about it for the
millionth time on tv
um and i'm sad that the cowboys
announced it themselves instead of me
breaking it
otherwise i thought it was great well i
mean now we could talk about what
jerry's gonna be able to do as the gm
and steven could be able to do as the uh
as the de facto um gm as well
and and how they can actually surround
him how they can protect him how they
can actually win
with this contract that's what makes it
easier
contract makes it easier it does this
year though right correct it makes it
easier this year correct
oh yeah yeah i mean it's much better
than going tag tag and
then next year who knows so what do they
do
before i let you go what do they do
what's dallas doing
what's their next uh they their shop
they're gonna end up shopping in the
discount section
and just build depth you know some
offensive line depth probably maybe some
tight end depth
um defensive line like that it's going
to be nothing exciting maybe sign a
woojie back
i don't think it's going to be exciting
but they never are that exciting in free
agency but usually effective
the philene's basement of the nfl is
that where is that where they're going
is what you're saying i thought filene's
is not in
business anymore is that accurate i
don't know it's definitely out of
business
yeah i get i want a new england
reference
i went in boston it's supposed to be
this institution i was really
underwhelmed
ian thanks for the call you you met
you're you're now free to microwave
whatever you were microwaving i
appreciate the time
now i gotta re-microwave it now but yeah
what were you microwaving what were you
doing
what are you doing um i got a little uh
little one a little
soup and uh bagel combo i got going on i
got eight minutes before i gotta get
ready for tv
okay so go okay go go for it there you
go ian rappaport
soup and a bagel and information right
here on the recharging show that's all
we're looking for
that's all we want out of our guests is
soup bagel information
not in that order